Tina's right
are you Abel Martinez Junior no you got
an ID on you
you don't have your ID on you at all no
you know you're social then
you don't know how your social you know
your name or date of birth
[Music]
what's your name
Juan
you under you understand what
falsification is right if you lie to me
about who you are
you don't have your ID or nothing no
what's in that bag that's you keep
clutching on your chest that's just
yours what's in it now you don't want to
tell me what it is what's in it you
don't have an ID or anything in it now
you're one one what
color spell it
h-u-n-h-g-o-r h-u-n-c-o-r
c-o-r-l-e-s driver's license
what's your date of birth
what's your date of birth I said nope
don't start the car don't start the car
get out the car get out the car get up
recording muted
get out the car
[Music]
165. he just ran us over he's leaving
people I got eyes on it it's Mercedes he
just tried to run us over
are you okay yeah
yeah
53 there's a female and a child in that
vehicle
[Laughter]